Joost
je hebt het vaak over de kosten van ons asielbeleid
hoeveel kost dat nou eigenlijk nou
dat is dus berekend op 24 miljard
euro per jaar
als we de huidige instroom houden
dan is dat wat we betalen
over de langere termijn
dat is natuurlijk onhoudbaar
onhoudbaar veel geld
wij zeggen die opvang
van asielzoekers moet in de regio's gebeuren
waar ze vandaan komen
daar moet 1 veilige opvang zijn
dat is niet alleen veel goedkoper
maar natuurlijk ook veel menselijker
voor de mensen zelf
en de euro's die wij hier besteden aan asiel
aan de hele asiel
de procedure
die kan daar zoveel effectiever worden besteed
dus het model moet omgekeerd worden
asiel ja
maar niet in Nederland maar daar